38 logements neufs prévus pour 2014 sur
magny les hameaux
entre la rue des écoles jean beaudin et
la rue paul cézanne la villa du hameau
verra le jour à la pointe de la chapelle
lacoste dans ce projet de type de
logement le premier donc c'est de la
location location sociale pour la moitié
des logements grosso modo et puis
l'autre partie est en accession aidée
ça touche principalement des familles en
construction et ça va leur permettre
d'avoir un prix au mètre carré pour
accéder à la propriété largement
inférieurs aux prix aujourd'hui
habituellement constatés sur la commune
le locataire accédant au bénéficie d'une
tva réduite à 5 5% au lieu de 19 6 pour
cette opération
il bénéficie aussi d'une exonération
d'impôt foncier pendant 15 ans il n'a
pas à payer les appels de fonds
contrairement à une vente en état futur
d'achèvement où on paye 20 % chez
notaire 35% au niveau des fondations
donc là il est exonéré de tout versement
jusqu'à la livraison
par contre pour être éligible à ce
processus d'acquisition il faut rentrer
dans des plafonds de ressources qui sont
alors je vais prendre l'exemple d'une
famille avec un enfant de 50000 euros
une et fiscale c'est ce qui apparaît sur
l'avis d'imposition 21 logements en
location-accession et 17 en locatif
social allant du 2 au 4 pièces
le rez-de-chaussée du bâtiment hébergera
des locaux médicaux et paramédicaux sur
370 m² dans un secteur privilégié en
centre bourg on a travaillé avec des
acteurs du domaine médical de la commune
pour leur proposer ce regroupement en un
même lieu qui sera donc le nôtre notre
pôle central
pour tous les soins sur la commune de
magny les hameaux infirmières dentistes
orthophonistes kinésithérapeutes sont
déjà prévus il ne manque plus qu'un
médecin généraliste pour lequel un appel
sera lancé prochainement
en attendant une réunion publique aura
lieu le mercredi 14 novembre à 20h30 à
l'hôtel de ville pour informer les
manier quoi présentation de projets
critères d'éligibilité planning de
commercialisation les dossiers de
candidature à récupérer les habitants
intéressés devront renvoyer leurs
dossiers avant le 28 novembre